- Are there any form
of protective measures
one could take before kissing a frog?
- There's two.
One is, don't kiss the frog.
The other one is
dental dams?
(classical music)
- I'm a princess of Iran.
- I'm a princess from a small area
in the Northern part of India.
- There's still a beauty
to having that history
behind the tale of being a princess.
- Disney kind of makes
it seem that princesses
have to look a certain way.
They don't really do much.
They sit at home and be beautiful.
I work like three jobs, I'm a hustler.
- I'm not really big on
reptiles or slimy animals.
- I actually love all animals.
I had two rats in college.
I had a pet rooster named Bob.
- It has never occurred to me,
as a princess, to kiss a frog.
- The frog might like lick my whole face.
I don't know.
- I'm ready to go for it.
- Yes, let's do it.
- This is Bruce the American Bullfrog.
He's a male.
He's got large eardrums.
I don't think anyone should kiss a frog.
There's always a chance, being a frog,
that it's got salmonella.
And in all the rivers in
California, there's giardia.
- I'll take the risk.
- All right , I'll just take the chance.
I'll take the chance.
- Yeah, you'll be fine.
That's Bruce.
(princess gasps)
- Oh my god, oh my god!
- Oh my god it is so big!
- What's all the stuff in him?
It's so jiggly and jelly.
- That's called guts.
- Oh, these are all guts right here?
- Yeah, he's a bit fat, but
we don't talk about that.
- He's in shape, everyone.
Do I hold him?
- Yeah, you can put both
hands together like that
and I'm gonna place him in your hand.
- Hiya, Bruce!
- Oh my god, he's so cute.
- He's all yours.
And on the count of three, lay one on him.
- Is he gonna jump in my face?
- God, I hope not.
- It's just staring at me.
- I know, he'll do that.
- This is really weird.
- I know.
Do it, do it!
- I'm freaking out now!
Hold on.
(shrieks)
- As punishment, if you don't
kiss a frog on the lips,
we turn him around.
- Oh my god.
- Yeah, you don't wanna do that.
(princess kisses)
He's just happy there, look.
Big smack, there we are.
(princess laughs)
May I have another?
- [Princess] One more?
(princess kisses)
- You can hear him, "Er."
- It was sticky, a little sticky.
And wet, and slimy.
- It's weird because his throat
keeps moving up and down.
- Oh, he winked at me!
- [Jules] Oh, he did.
That means, he wants your phone number.
- That was an extremely
strange experience.
- Well, my ex-boyfriend
did not kiss like that,
but he was very shy and
motionless, just like Bruce,
so it's kind of the same thing.
- The frog was bigger than
I thought it would be.
And there were just some features,
that I just, I didn't
realize they look like that.
- So I thought it was
gonna stick its tongue out
and go for the make-out, you know,
and be like that wild
child, but he really wasn't.
- It's cool to say,
you got to kiss a frog.
How many people can say that, honestly.
("England Countdown")
- Oh he's got big leg muscles.
- Yeah, and he does ballet too.
And one, and two, and one, and two.
- Oh, you're so talented.